imagine powering a cellphone with the
heat from a blowtorch
well there's materials that are out
there called thermal electrics that can
do just that
hi my name is Aneesa Ramirez welcome to
my lab at Yale University I'd like to
share with you materials called thermal
electrics which can convert heat into
electricity and we can use this to power
small appliances let's look at thermal
electrics in action here I have a
thermal electric that's actually
connected to a fan now in order to make
this work I have to have one side of the
thermoelectric hot and the other side
cold so I'm going to dip these legs into
the water let's see what happens when I
turn this on wow that's really cool and
this thermal electric is going to keep
going keep spinning that fan as long as
one side is hot and one side is cold now
in order to understand thermal electrics
we have to go back and understand how
electrons move in a metal electrons are
able to move any way they're like inside
of a metal it's like a huge atomic mosh
pit where they're crashing into each
other when the metal is cold electrons
move very very slowly just like these
ball bearings when metals are hot the
electrons move very very very quickly
and they continue to crash into each
other even more now let's say that we
have a metal that has one side that's
hot and one side that's cold sort of
like these blocks here the electrons are
going to move from the hot side to the
cold side where they're moving very
rapidly to where they're not moving as
rapidly and the ability of an electron
to move from one side to the other is
called this conductivity now two
different materials will have this same
behavior where electrons will move from
the hot side to the cold side but
they'll do this to two different extents
because they have different conductivity
so let's say that we were to connect
these two materials together once again
the electrons would be moving from the
hot side to the cold side but the
electrons that accumulate on the cold
side would be different there'd be an
imbalance think of it this way here I
have two buckets of marbles where the
marbles represent electrons you can see
that there's an imbalance from the two
different materials well when I move
electrons from one side to the other
side when electrons move from one metal
to another metal
we have electricity all it takes is heat
here I have a thermoelectric that's
connected to a multimeter and a
multimeter is going to register the flow
of electrons what I'm gonna do is place
my hand on top of the thermoelectric and
you'll see that the number of electrons
that's flowing through this will change
watch this you can see the values
changing that's really cool
so where our thermal electrics used well
wherever you need power in a remote
place thermal electrics have you covered
so currently we use thermal electrics in
space Voyager uses thermal electrics and
it's a perfect setup one side is heated
by the Sun the other side is cooled by
space also cars are a great example for
thermal electrics cars generate about
70% waste heat if we put thermal
electrics in the right spot we can
convert that heat into electricity and
power something simple like a cell phone
also companies are starting to use
thermal electrics on their exhaust
stacks as a way to capture the heat to
create electricity
thermal electrics are really hot they
use an imbalance of electrons in two
different materials and generate
electricity using heat that we otherwise
would have wasted I'm Aneesa Ramirez
thank you for joining me in my lab at
Yale University and I hope you'll join
us for another material marvel